he's one of the best at what he does the
director and filmmaker and documentarian
is back with a four-part series muhammad
ali starts sunday september 19th at 8
p.m on pbs ken burns here on the rich
eisen show how are you sir
i am doing very well how are you doing i
am doing well what uh what attracted you
to the subject matter ken well this is
co-directed with my oldest daughter
sarah burns and her husband david
mcmahon we did the central part five
film and jackie robinson together so in
some ways this is a kind of obvious
choice but a dear friend of ours a
biographer of ali most recent biographer
jonathan i just
said as we were working on jackie seven
or eight years ago this is a great story
and we of course went oh my god how did
we ever spend 40 years doing this and
not have thought about it before so we
just dove in wholeheartedly and i think
you know i grew up with him i remember
my dad telling me that he won gold and
olympics when i was seven years old uh
the uh the story is just beyond anything
of our wildest understanding and and
look i should just say there are a lot
of documentaries
and there are lots of good ones really
really good films and we're not
attempting to replace them or change
them we just noticed that they were
about a specific fight or a series of
fights or about a a couple year period
we really wanted to do soup to nuts from
you know birth and boyhood and jim crow
segregated louisville kentucky to death
by parkinson's not five years ago in
2016. so how how does one approach an
iconic figure that has been talked about
and documented uh his story in so many
different ways as you just pointed out
how how do you
approach attack such
an endeavor ken burns
you know i remember shelby's foot said
to me when i was working on the civil
war he said god is the greatest
dramatist which is a way of saying and
then and then and then so we just
literally start at the beginning
obviously we're going to do deep
research we're going to read we're going
to try to find and we did find in
database 15 000 photographs for 500
hours of footage of him and particularly
interviews of him that some of which
have never been seen the light of day
since they were originally taken
you know home movies and and stuff that
definitely is from folks garages that
has never been seen before the families
called me up and said wow i never saw
that picture of him holding me and
saying you don't you know your daddy's
the baddest in the world so we feel like
we did a good jeep dive and then it's
just working with scholars and people to
make sure that we
can not just animate the boxing story
which is like the collected works of
william shakespeare
but also this journey in faith uh just
becoming a member of the nation of islam
it's not enough just to mention it or
describe what it was it's an ongoing
fluid process of a young man finding
something that gave some meaning to his
life at that point and then maturing
with it over the course of his life
where he he sort of sheds it in order to
embrace you know the the more orthodox
the more you know mainstream islam which
the sect the nation of islam was and
it's also about the personal life four
wives you know that means three divorces
uh lots of kids that means children of
divorces
money all of that sort of stuff it was
an attempt to have a comprehensive
integrated view of the whole of muhammad
ali and if you think about it he touches
every single
single issue of the last half of the
20th century the role of sports
in in the united states the role of a
black athlete the definitions of black
masculinity um about the the dimensions
of the civil rights movement about faith
about religion about islam about
politics about war i mean all of that he
touches and all of those themes are
still relevant so in the end of the day
you have a film
i think that is about freedom it's very
difficult for a black man in this
continent to
escape the specific gravity of that
circumstance it's about courage a young
man in his 20s who says he's willing to
stand up to a machine gun fire rather
than go against his faith we took it as
a political statement but it was a faith
statement to not fight in vietnam and
then of course a very difficult topic
one that the fcc a four-letter word that
the fcc allows you and me to use but we
don't have a very good
um track record of actually talking
about it in depth which is this is a
story about love he dies the most
beloved person on the planet after being
in the 1960s and early 70s seemingly one
of the most divisive people because i
say seemingly only because i think it's
a lot of what was projected into him
rather than what he himself did ken
burns here on the rich eisen show
muhammad ali is coming your way to
your pbs station starting september 19th
this sunday at eight eastern a four-part
series what did you learn about him
everything i mean i thought i knew him
like my whole life accompanied his and
and i watched him i met him you know i
just think there's all of these
dimensions there's great humor there's
great pathos there's great you know uh
tension just you could take the first
list and fight and you could almost you
know no hollywood producer would you
know buy it or the
thrilla in manila which in which he said
he was closest to death or when he wins
the championship from foreman when most
people in this corner are worried that
he's going to be killed
he actually destroys foreman uh you know
there's there's all of that and then
there's the
the intimate moments where we sort of
say well in that early period all he did
was brag and make jokes and recite
poetry and you know i'm i'm so bad i can
drown a drink of water and kill a dead
tree when in fact there's several things
that we discovered that were so
thoughtful and wise that belied his age
belied the the job that he was doing the
career that he'd chosen and we're
speaking to sort of big heavy things you
know and i i'm i'm just stunned at the
intimacy of who this guy he knew early
on he put on boxing gloves and within a
few months he's saying i'm going to be
the greatest and everybody's going like
yeah right you don't have anything and
he was the greatest or he'd say stuff
like well the
honorable elijah muhammad doesn't want
me to box so i don't need to box and the
guy says you give up boxing is here i
don't need to box but i know i'm here
for a purpose and you could see that
early on as a young kid he knew he was
put on this earth for something else the
thing that you know really struck me
when he passed away ken burns was
the number of people and i'm not just
talking about famous people peers or
people who covered him
the number of just regular
citizens
around the globe that posted photographs
that they had with him
that that he stopped and took
photographs and talked to people and
everyone had a story honestly like it
was wild to me how
much
he got around you know it's crazy
you know
the people's channel
i mean when he says i'm pretty as a girl
i'm i'm beautiful i'm black i'm
beautiful we think it was a part of a
unexpected braggadocio that up until
that point athletes weren't supposed to
behave and certainly black athletes
weren't supposed to behave that way but
what he was doing was he was giving
permission to people black people around
the united states but oppressed people
everywhere
the the the permission to feel good
about themselves and so
he is on so many cotton continents
africa
you know north africa
middle east asia
south america as well as here at home a
beloved figure and europe as well a
beloved figure and as david remnick the
editor of the new yorker and a
biographer of early clay
life eaton just said that you know by
the time he dies he's revered almost
like a religious
figure like the buddha everybody has
that story because he took the time it
wasn't like okay we're done with the
autograph session how much did i make
let's go
it was
no pay just here here i am i will give
you until you're satisfied i met him
once it was the same way it's just the
generosity of spirit
it didn't matter
you know it was just so pure and uh i'm
i'm still impressed with what he is and
having said that rich you know this film
doesn't pull any punches about his
failings you know they're all over and
in every single episode and he becomes
aware of them and tries his best at the
end of his life to atone he feels
there's a tallying angel and that the
way he's treated women his
unfaithfulness to his wives the way he
cut off malcolm x so abruptly when
ordered to by elijah muhammad just
before malcolm x was
murdered by the nation of islam um and
also the way he had treated joe frazier
by using as the scholar todd boyd said
you know the language of a white racist
about his opponent he said this is the
ultimate conscious black guy using the
language of a white racist he and he
says something that was a key for me and
understanding ali says i just think in
this instance he used his powers for
evil instead of good and i go oh that's
right i'm
we're making a film about a superhero
that's what this is
this is a superhero in every sense of
the word the marvel stuff is just you
know doa as far as i'm concerned this is
somebody who lived a larger than life
life that we can all
participate in and take what we can from
it's not that you know the world had
opinions of him
the world changed its opinions of him as
he grew and more importantly we grew and
i think one of the great gifts of
muhammad ali is he asked us to be
different than we were
the filmmaker director and uh writer of
uh co-writer and co-director of muhammad
ali which is going to be on pbs
four-part series sunday september 19th
at 8 eastern time ken burns here on the
rich eisen show and the few minutes i
have left with you i would be remiss if
i did not speak to one of the greatest
chroniclers and uh documentaries of uh
baseball uh from that spectacular
baseball uh film that you put together
uh back in the 90s uh all the way
through um so
what do you make of ohtani
somebody who's
i would love to get your perspective on
what shouio itani is putting out on the
field right now it's just so exciting
because you've got a the obvious the
shades of babe ruth um and you've got a
kind of revitalized sense i mean the
game everybody's always willing to write
baseball's obituary i heard i had a
quote in the film in the first episode
of the baseball series in which
in 1858 they were writing the obituary
of baseball you know some guy named pete
o'brien was saying oh you know they
don't play baseball the way they used to
when i was a kid i don't mean the rules
are different but the spirit's gone or
this is gone you know
and we've been writing that obituary for
so long and it's always this
ever-changing sense of surprise as
showay otani just gives you this
opportunity to go
this is why this is the best game ever
invented you know it's not just that the
defense has the ball it's not just that
there's no clock it's not just that the
human being scores but that we have so
many different personalities and so many
different skill sets as the greatest
basketball player or one of the greatest
basketball players of all time
discovered when he tried momentarily to
switch and could not hit a buck 85 in
the national pastime
this is a really tough thing to do to
take a bit of turned northern asher now
maple and hit at horse hyde or whatever
it is now coming at you at 100 miles an
hour and deciding in a millisecond to
hit it and that the people who
sail
seven times out of ten
are going to the hall of fame they do
that for 15 years it is great seinfeld
once told me the greatest thing he
thinks about baseball is that it's the
only sport uh where uh it's the
the equality the democracy of talent and
physique that essentially somebody the
size of aaron judge and the size of jose
altuve are both mvp candidates in the
sport and that's not true of football or
hockey or basketball right i mean you do
have your spud web every once in a while
but look at maddox you know greg maddox
looks like an accountant uh dan o'cram
said in our film you know
it's like he well he should be coming
off the mound with a briefcase right and
he's one of the greatest pitchers of the
last you know couple of generations now
i know you have to go but i do want to
shoehorn one last in here for your
muhammad ali film give me the good stuff
on cosell you got some good stuff on
cosell yeah i think delgad as david
remnick says in the film he got
cassie clay i mean he too long he bugged
him by not changing the name but at the
beginning he's pretty critical of him
for the braggadocio but he comes around
and understands him as a kind of avatar
of a new athlete not just a black
athlete but a new athlete and i think
they both
um particularly ali who's a master
showman and promoter understood they
could ride each other's coattails even
with the antagonism at the heart of it i
think is a deep love and cosell really
understood
the change agent that ali was and he
came around him and he helped a lot of
us i remember watching stuff with my dad
and howard cosell was the first person
that gave me a
permission to love muhammad ali
at a time when people were still just so
uh opposed to him for the change of the
name for the bragging for the changing
to muslim and all that sort of stuff and
then the anti-war stuff i was i agreed
with that but
um it it it
cosell's an important part of this story
an important dimension a guy from
brooklyn who kind of realizes
that
he can go far on this guy and this guy
can go far on him and that what they're
celebrating is the essential humanity of
both people i love it and i'm sure
you've heard the billy crystal story of
what muhammad ali leaned over and said
to him and asked him during kosel's
funeral right you heard that story no
tell me he said billy crystal says he's
sitting next to muhammad ali at the
funeral in the casket's right there in
front of him and ollie leans over and
says do you think he's got his toupee on
in there that's what he said
[Laughter]
that's what he said that's what crystal
said i mean that's just unbelievable
well i'm honored that i could give you a
little tidbit after your your
documentary is in the cannon getting
ready to be and i always learn stuff
after the fact that's all right and you
go oh man
you know somebody told me that you know
the parkinson's have taken over and that
that ali was not pathetic but just it
was so sad that he couldn't get up at
all the different uh things at frasier's
funeral and everybody's jumping up and
jumping finally at the end he gets up
but he can't stop
clapping and lonnie has to sort of stop
the arms from clapping and i just you
know they just broke my heart just broke
my heart i came out back the frasier
never forgave him even though ali
apologized to him i cannot wait to see
it ken burns thank you for coming on
again starting sunday 8 p.m eastern on
pbs the poor four-part series muhammad
ali let's do this more often i really
enjoyed this challenge
i'm there anytime thank you that's ken
burns right here on the rich eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here